SPEAKER 1: Welcome
to VM End-to-End,
a show where we have a VM
skeptic and a VM enthusiast
try and hash out, are VMs
still amazing and awesome.
So Brian, thanks
for coming in today.
I appreciate you.
SPEAKER 2: Happy to be here.
Let's get to it.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Yes.
Last time, we talked about
are Cloud VMs relevant.
Are VMs still relevant
in a Cloud native future?
You said, definitively yes.
So today, I want to go a
little bit deeper and find out
what exactly is a Cloud VM.
Can you help me out?
SPEAKER 2: Absolutely.
Let's get into it.
And you know first
it's a virtual machine.
I think most of what people
know about virtual machines
is all true for Cloud VMs.
And the thing I hope we
get out of this today
is that there's a bunch of extra
stuff you might not know about
or might not think to look into.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So it's like a Cloud, it's
like a regular VM but not.
So a regular VM, we said
it's a machine on a computer.
You said a Cloud VM is
a little bit different.
What are the
specific differences
with the real parts,
the physical parts?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
In the end, it's all
running on real computers
somewhere, right?
So when the VM is up and
running, you've got a real CPU,
you've got real
memory, and I think
the parts that are the
most fluid are probably
the disk and the network.
And in Google Cloud,
those are both software
defined services that give
you a lot of flexibility.
So I think the takeaway
here is, instead
of thinking about it as
a slice of one computer,
think about it as like the
slice of a data center's
worth of computers.
SPEAKER 1: Wow, all right.
So that's an interesting
thought to me.
And what I'm curious
about is, if I
have a slice of a
data center, how
is that manageable or usable?
Like if I wanted to
make a video game, what
do I do with a slice
of a data center?
SPEAKER 2: I think
that's a great example.
So it's down to
what are you trying
to do and we then take a
bunch of the variables that
are possible and kind
of group them up.
So we group them up into compute
optimized, memory optimized,
accelerator optimized
and then general purpose.
So the compute
ones are for where
you need the lowest
latency single threaded
computation possible.
Memory is where you need the
maximum memory you can possibly
stuff in a machine.
You're running like an
in-memory database or something.
And the accelerator
ones are for when
you need a GPU or one of
our Tensor Processing Units.
And then for everything
else, general purpose.
SPEAKER 1: General purpose.
Just like most people,
just need a laptop.
So you have these
specific groupings,
maybe families of
machines ordered,
within those families
can I specialize?
Like if I need a high-end
gaming laptop versus just
like a low-end gaming laptop?
SPEAKER 2: Absolutely.
And the first knob you
have is just how big it is.
So how many CPUs and memory?
So you can have a two core
machine or a 20 or a 460 core
machine.
And so they get
bigger and smaller.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, really.
And up to 12 terabytes
of memory right now.
And like those numbers keep
getting bigger over time.
So when you see this,
it might be different.
And by default, those come in
kind of like a preset ratio.
So they kind of grow together.
Part of the main
reason people wanted
to use containers at all
is that not everything fits
in that exact
shape, so you end up
kind of orphaning
some of the capacity
and kind of wasting money.
So we also allow you, with
the general purpose machines,
to pick your own ratio.
So if you're like,
Oh, I know this
is a really CPU heavy thing but
I don't need that much memory,
you can make a
computer that's shape
and you'll only pay for
what you actually need.
SPEAKER 1: Oh,
that's really cool.
OK, so if you can
make your own shape,
somewhere there has
to be physical memory.
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
SPEAKER 1: So where do we
get this in a Cloud VM?
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
So when you go to
set one of these up,
we find one of the
machines out there
that has space for the shape
you want and start it up there.
And so that's this kind
of a Tetris problem
becomes not your
problem, and we're
big enough that
there's almost always
a good spot for that to fit.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And so these are
all on one machine
it just sounded like there.
SPEAKER 2: Oh, so there's a
data center worth of machines.
And so when you go
to start yours up,
we find the right spot for it.
Find a computer
that has open space.
SPEAKER 1: So tell
me a little bit more
about disks than in this
slice of a data center world.
SPEAKER 2: So if
we can just turn it
on on like any one of these
computers in a data center,
how do the disks work?
Where's my data?
And so by default, our
disks are almost always
network attached storage.
And so instead of a physical
disk plugged into one computer,
those still exist,
but we provide
a virtual disk made up of
hundreds or thousands of disks
plugged into a whole
bunch of computers.
And then assemble the
blocks together virtually,
which gives you--
you actually get
higher performance
than you might get normally.
So like the throughput
is very fast.
And then you get a
bunch of the features
that you might
expect from a SAN,
like a Storage Area Network.
SPEAKER 1: So you can attach
and detach on the fly.
You can--
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
SPEAKER 1: OK,
that's really cool.
SPEAKER 2: So you can do that.
You can resize it, and use
the snapshots to take backups.
But the resize thing
is kind of amazing.
Like if you run
out of disk space,
you can actually
make the disk bigger
while the computer's running.
SPEAKER 1: Ryan, you're
blowing my mind right now.
I gotta act skeptical.
I'm going to be skeptical.
You're blowing my mind.
Something I'm curious about.
When I'm using containers, I
can select an operating system.
And so the benefit of that
is, I can write applications
to operating systems
that I know and love.
I can only use what I need.
Is there that same concept in
the VM world or am I stuck?
Am I forced to use certain
types of operating systems
to use a Cloud VM?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah,
very similar concept.
Whereas in a container
it's mostly just the
files that make up that
system per for runtime.
Whereas here, we have the
whole operating system running.
But other than that, it's really
pretty much the same concept.
You have most workloads
these days are
running on Linux or Windows.
And so we provide kind of
premade images of Debian,
Santos, Core OS, Ubuntu,
Red Hat, Enterprise, SUSE
and Windows Server Data Center,
a bunch of different versions.
So when you create a VM you say,
OK, I want it to run this OS
and it makes a copy of that
image kind of on the fly
and boots your
machine off of that.
SPEAKER 1: OK,
that's really cool.
Can you use your own at All
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So if you-- two ways to do it.
So one, if you want to use one
of these OS's and just kind
of put your flavor on
it, add some tools,
configure it the way you want
it to be, you can boot off
one of them and then make a
new image based off of the work
you did.
SPEAKER 1: Nice.
SPEAKER 2: So that's
a really common thing.
And then if you want
to, it's a block device.
And so you can make a
customized version of an OS
or develop a whole
new OS, and as long
as that runs in a virtual
machine, you can boot off of it
and go.
SPEAKER 1: I got
to be honest, it's
sounding like there's
a lot of flexibility.
Like all these things--
I'm like, well, in
containers you can do this.
You're like Yes, you can
do this in VM world too.
SPEAKER 2: And a lot
of it's based on that.
So this is kind of a high-level
version of what a Cloud VM is.
You can basically run anything
that runs on a computer.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
We just specified really quick.
There's some virtual parts,
there's some physical parts.
Your disks are going to be
spread out over a wide data
center, pulled together to
give you more reliability, more
consistency.
A lot of times you said
it's even faster throughput.
This is really cool.
What I'm curious
about is, what are
like actual like things that
are non-obvious extensions
of this stuff.
Like, what can I do with this?
SPEAKER 2: I think
one of the underused
or kind of under known
things is actually
running a container, like
kind of one container per VM
as a pattern.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
why would I do that?
SPEAKER 2: So a couple
of different reasons.
Like one, containers have become
kind of a distribution format.
So a lot of software is already
ready to go in a container.
And sometimes you
don't want to deal
with setting up a whole cluster
or managing some other stuff,
you just want to run one thing.
So that's a reason to do it.
And then sometimes
there's constraints.
Like that particular
thing, it might make sense
to run it on a
very large machine
for a short amount of time.
Or it needs some
particular configuration
that you might not
have otherwise.
SPEAKER 1: And still use
that packaging of containers.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, one to one.
SPEAKER 1: OK, that
makes a lot of sense.
In theory, I could still run
containers for a lot of this.
What are some other
features of Cloud VMs
that you're excited about.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So one I think is, it's
really commonly used
in almost all architectures.
Pretty much everybody
has a load balancer
when you have multiple
machines, right?
And the non-obvious
like cool thing
is that, Yes, we
have a load balancer.
But it's a load
balancer service that
is provided at the
data center level.
It's not some
particular computer
that has a certain capacity
that as soon as you hit,
like things start slowing
down or getting overdrawn.
So you're actually configuring
the data center level load
balancer that Google uses
for YouTube and Gmail
to run your own machines.
SPEAKER 1: So one,
that's just really cool
thinking about that concept.
But what I'm blown
away right now
is thinking in kubernetes I
use services all the time.
And GKE, the load
balancer that's provided,
is the Cloud load
balancer, the Google one.
So even then, I'm using the
Google Cloud load balancer.
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
SPEAKER 1: My question
though is, like I can still
access this load
balancer, it sounds
like it's configured already
for me through something
like Kubernetes.
Is there a reason to go lower?
Is there a reason
to go to this level?
SPEAKER 2: So if you're
already using Kubernetes,
use Kubernetes.
But I think those
patterns are super useful.
And not all software is
set up to run in containers
or is so easy to do there.
So if you want to use
those same patterns--
SPEAKER 1: That pattern of
having a single endpoint
that you can communicate with.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So there's this idea of
having a known endpoint that
provides this service.
And then there's a
group of containers,
usually in Kubernetes, but a
group of computers in this case
that do that.
And once you do that,
you have a known endpoint
and a group of computers.
And we call that
group in Compute
Engine a managed instance group.
Then you can put a
bunch of logic on that.
So it's actually a
service in and of itself.
So it handles starting up new
machines when they're needed.
If you turn the dial up and
you're like Oh, I have five now
and I want to have 10,
it starts the new ones.
That can be set up to
be run automatically
depending on the load you get.
And then you can spread
those out across the world.
You can have some of them
running in one country,
some of them running
somewhere else,
and route the traffic to the
closest one for your users,
that sort of thing.
SPEAKER 1: I'm going to have
to find out more about this.
I'm going to have
to dig in deeper
because I want to
be skeptical and I'm
like this all sounds amazing.
I don't want this
conversation to go too long,
but I'm definitely going to
want to dig in deeper here.
In fact, maybe we
can have an episode--
would you count this as
like admin, infrastructure,
networking?
What is this that we
were just talking about?
SPEAKER 2: I think
we should dive
into the networking a bit more
next into how that actually
works.
When I say it's not running
on one box, wait, what?
How do you distribute
traffic if it's not
going through one machine?
So let's do networking.
And then I'm just--
I love the disks and there's a
lot more to talk about there.
Let's do that.
What else do you
want to hear about?
SPEAKER 1: Disks for sure.
I want to hear about cost.
I'm going to have to do some
my own homework after hearing
about like machine
families and all of this.
I need to go start
and create a VM.
And I hope people listening
at home do the same thing.
Yes.
Because I'm going to be
more skeptical next episode.
I'm going deeper.
But this episode,
I got to admit,
Cloud VMs sounds pretty cool.
SPEAKER 2: They are.
Give it a try.
SPEAKER 1: All right, well
thank you Brian and I'll
catch up with you next time.
SPEAKER 2: See you soon.